(upbeat music)
- My name's Felicia, and I'm gonna learn
how to drive stick shift in a manual car.
- I think that it's gonna be difficult
to drive stick in Manhattan
for the first time.
Driving automatic in
Manhattan is pretty stressful.
- I feel like it's gonna be okay.
I learn quickly and can adapt
to high pressure environments.
- My name is Kris, I'm a
professional driving instructor.
Today I'm gonna be teaching
Felicia and Benjamin
how to drive stick shift in New York City.
Okay, so, getting this
to move is the hard part.
You have three pedals there.
First one to the left is a
clutch, that's kinda small.
And then the two pedals
which are still the same
in an automatic, you got
your break and your gas.
One of the things you
need to understand is
when to use your clutch;
starting, stopping and shifting.
Let's disengage this.
Uh, pull up and then try to push it down.
It's a little tough.
Yeah pull it up, and
then squeeze the button.
Yeah there you go.
- Should I--
- Yeah just keep that held.
- Should I squeeze at the same time?
- Yeah, pull up and then squeeze.
So, we're gonna try to go.
Control it, if you wanna
go a little bit more.
Yep yep yep yep yep, good.
- Is everyone ready?
- Full of traffic.
Actually I'm gonna turn
on the hazards here.
Alright, so, is your foot on the break?
- Yes.
- Let go of it.
There we are, okay.
- Woo (laughs loudly)
- When you feel it vibrating that means
you're almost stalling.
Too quick, too quick, too quick.
- Ow, sorry.
Oh, the guy behind me is mad.
(horn beeping)
- Relax.
- Ow, sorry.
- Okay, try again.
- Can I let go of the break now?
- Yeah, you have to let go of the break.
- Oh, oh okay.
- Steady, oh too quick,
too quick, too quick.
Wanna feel it roll first, work from there.
You gotta hold it still for a second.
Easy.
- Okay.
Oops.
- Was your foot still
on the break on that?
- I think so.
- Yeah
- Okay.
- No break, no break.
No need for the break right now.
Steady, steady.
Steady with the left foot.
Uh, too quick.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah, yes!
- Oh, that's great!
And now can I release?
- Yeah, you can, you're off
to the races now, go ahead.
- Yes, okay.
That guy's gotta calm down.
Oh (bleep), there's a biker.
- A little too close on the
right, close on the right.
- Okay sorry, sorry.
Alright okay.
(laughs)
I don't drive that much
in the city overall
so it's hard to remember sometimes.
- A little bit more gas, there you go.
Okay, there you go, we're off.
- I'm gettin' it.
- Alright.
Go ahead, keep goin'.
- Alright, yeah.
It's like jazz now, you
got all these pieces
happening at the same time.
- You listen to jazz music?
- Uh no, but I assume it's like this.
- Listen to my instructions.
Clutch down.
Clutch uh no, that's the shift there.
The left foot.
- Oh, sorry!
- Okay, I'm gonna fix it, hold on.
- Don't do anything.
- Wait-
- Just keep your foot there.
- Foot on the clutch?
- Foot on the clutch, yep.
- Clutch is the pedal right?
- What do you think so far?
- Still feel like I'm not doing it right.
(both laugh)
- Steady that, steady that.
- Beautiful.
- There we go.
- Gorgeous!
- Alright.
- I'm really great at this.
- I'm sweating (laughs)
- I think I did a great job.
- I do wanna take more lessons.
I still wanna be able to drive
a car in another country.
Be able to drive a sports car.
- I feel like I accomplished a lot.
Kris, the instructor, was very
articulate and descriptive.
I think I did well!
- Thank you so much, I'm a pro now.